let's make like bread and loaf I just
made that up I'm freestyling right now
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'll be fine without me
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less hopefully less debt today is
what we're gonna be talking about my
name is Joshua fields Millburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists indeed welcome to episode
number 28 we're just talking about debt
today and I'll tell you this we are in
the middle of a debt crisis especially
in the United States but really in the
Western world overall it seems like we
didn't learn our our a lesson from 2008
and that crash and we're accumulating
more and more debt as a as a society the
average person in America has four
active credit cards and in his or her
wallet yeah one in ten Americans has
more than ten active credit cards that
was me back in my Lotus eating twenties
I I had 14 active dessert like the lows
credit card Oh totally it sometimes I
would put more on a banana republic card
then I then I would on you know a
regular regular MasterCard whatever the
Republic he means Brooks Brothers yeah
also I had a Brooks Brothers card as
well no I had both and and so one in ten
Americans has ten or more active credit
cards the average credit card debt in
the United States right now is more than
$15,000 that's insane and and so it's
like six months salary for a lot of
people oh my goodness yeah I mean it's
why if I if I look if I look at overall
consumer debt and in the United States
it's approaching twelve trillion dollars
what's the national
it's close to 12 trillion yeah I think I
think why it might even be higher than
that now but but yeah so so we're
approaching the national debt and so
let's talk about what that means really
because 12 trillion is impossible for us
to wrap our mind around if I were to go
out and spend a dollar every single
second one dollar second one to $3 $4 $5
without sleeping Ryan if I didn't sleep
and I spent a dollar a second it would
only take me 31,000 years to spend one
trillion dollars Wow and we have 12
trillion dollars in debt let's put it in
perspective even more if you went out
and spent 1 million dollars million
dollars every single day if you would
have been doing that since the birth of
the Buddha you still would not have
spent 1 trillion dollars by now and we
have 12 trillion dollars worth of debt
we are in the middle of a debt crisis by
the way the national debt is 18 trillion
that's what I was thinking I thought it
was close to 19 at this point that is
insane though we keep adding to it so
that that's the the national debt for
the United States our consumer debt
which is mortgages and credit cards and
car loans and and second mortgages and
refinancing and and payday loans and all
of these other things twelve trillion
dollars almost and and it's not there
isn't a lot of Hope in sight and the
reason we have a debt crisis right now
is we have an education crisis and we
hope to educate you today on some of our
ways because Ryan and I have been on I
would say all three sides of this
equation Ryan and I grew up really poor
didn't have very much money and and we
were very discontented by our lack of
money and then of course we climbed the
corporate ladder throughout our 20s made
good money made outstanding money at the
pinnacle of my career I was making a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
but I was spending even better money and
had massive amounts of debt had sover
over six figures of debt and that
doesn't count my mortgage I had close to
half a million dollars in debt if you
added my mortgage in there and so what
we experienced was both sides there but
now we experience a different side
almost this of this triangle of living
we were
poor and then we made good money and
then we became the minimalist we walk
away from corporate careers made
appreciably less money but in the
process sort of living more
intentionally living more deliberately
and part of that was being more
deliberate with the money that we have
and and so we're gonna talk to you about
that today we're gonna answer some
questions and our first voicemail
question is actually were gonna play two
back-to-back here because they're both
kind of about credit cards they're
fairly similar but they were different
enough that we included both we
obviously can't include everyone's
voicemails when they call them but these
were we're different so we have a one
voicemail from Andy in Chicago and then
Erika in Iowa listen listen to those and
then we'll come back with some answers I
am trying to pay down my credit card
debts right now and I am finally getting
close to paying off my highest interest
on the credit card and I was just
wondering um once I get this paid up
should I just go ahead and cancel it
I know I've read that you know you don't
want to cancel your credit cards right
away because it'll ruin your credit
score blah blah blah but after kind of
adopting the minimalist lifestyle I
don't really want credit cards anymore
so I was just looking to get your advice
on what to do once I get done with the
credit card can get them all paid off
just go ahead and cancel them or if I
should hold on to them for a rainy day I
know that just in case is not the kind
of thing that we want to do thanks Andy
here's a question from Erica as well
currently I am debt free but I have
credit cards and I have actually a
safety net that's bigger than the limit
on my credit cards so I'm kind of
battling like white so you can keep it I
don't use it really
um I didn't know if you guys had credit
cards or if you know once you paid them
off you just quote them all out and then
I guess the second prong of that is you
know how concerned are you with you know
your credit scores I mean if you have
you know healthy safety nets and smart
investments and you're saving for your
future um you know I I don't know I
guess I just want to know financially if
you know you find credit cards necessary
and are you concerned with your credit
score with you know closing all these
close you know your consumer accounts
and your credit cards so you guys don't
use your credit cards you hold on to
your credit cards well you know that's a
pretty obvious answer to me if you're
not using them then then get rid of them
Andy buddy man if you are someone who
has gotten yourself into some massive
credit card debt paying that off and
then holding on to it for a rainy day
that doesn't sound like the best idea to
me I mean the I do understand that you
do need some type of securities and some
type of safety net but Andy I would
encourage you to yes cancel your credit
card and if you need something for a
rainy day then do what erica has done
and and get a safety net Erica yeah I
mean you have a safety net that's bigger
than your credit card limit you don't
need that credit card absolutely not I
would say to both of these folks yeah
cancer your credit cards yeah your
credit score might go down for a little
bit but at the end of the day if you are
staying out of debt you don't need a
credit score I mean I hope to one day
have a zero credit score just like Dave
Ramsey I'm not there yet but uh but but
yeah well Josh and I are not super
concerned on our credit scores in fact
some people would argue well you should
be concerned because what if you want to
go run a place so Josh what if you have
a zero credit card score but you want to
go rent a place in your FICO score right
how would you how would you prove that
you could still rent a place without a
credit score yeah it's an interesting
it's an interesting thing it's not
actually a credit score it's a debt
score and that's a good point that's the
problem we have there are people who
make ten thousand dollars a year which
is not very much money it's well below
the poverty line
you could have an 800 beacon score
because you've done all the the massage
to the game so much that you have
improved your credit score but you know
what an apartment complex or a place is
gonna rent you a house they're not gonna
approve you to rent their home if you
make only $10,000 a year the way that
that a credit works is you are proving
that you can you have the ability to go
deeper into debt so these aren't credit
cards they are debt cards you don't have
a credit score you have a debt score and
you're saying but what what if one day I
want to get a car loan what you
shouldn't want to get a car loan ever
you should never ever have a car loan
you should buy the car you can afford if
you need a car loan you can't afford
that car definition yeah yeah there's
one exception here I'm not gonna yell at
anyone who who gets a mortgage so so for
me for the last several years I've
thought about buying or or building a
house potentially now I'll tell you what
I would do in terms of buying or
building a house I'd have to have at
least 20% down for me it's got to be 50%
but at least 20% down for the house and
I would do no more than a seven-year
fixed-rate mortgage now we hear this all
the time that
yeah well it's a 30-year mortgage
fixed-rate and it's like well 30-year
mortgage I'm 35 years old I gonna pay on
the mortgage so I'm 65 I plan on living
in the same house so I'm till I'm 65
probably not but even if I did I don't
want to make those payments till I'm 65
years old so what we do right now is we
we buy I say buy and quotes here houses
that we can't necessarily afford it's
just the bank gives us the enough money
because they assume we're gonna be able
to make payments on it and we're gonna
have that same income for the rest of
our lives well I have news for you the
average person changes careers seven
times throughout their lives now it's
not it's not the same it's not the same
thing that we had 30 years ago where you
you went and you worked in a factory and
you've retired with a pension at age 50
or 55 it just doesn't work like that
anymore and so for me yes I would
consider having a home mortgage if I was
able to put 50% down to a seven-year
mortgage I would do up to a 15-year
mortgage I wouldn't personally but I
wouldn't yelling at anyone for for doing
that but a 30-year mortgage there's only
two countries in the world that do that
and and it's becoming more popular in
some other countries but it's only the
standard in two countries now but a lot
of countries have seen that oh look the
banks in America let people do this so
we're going to we're gonna start
offering that as an option as well
do not get fooled do not get pulled into
that and by the way if I needed a
mortgage and I had a zero credit score
it doesn't matter it you get something
called underwriting you find a good
local credit union or a good local bank
a good local broker and they do
underwriting based on your income and
your assets and if you can afford a
house then it's not a problem your
credit score is literally irrelevant in
that situation you shouldn't worry about
your credit score the only time you want
to worry about your credit score is if
you just have a bad credit score and a
zero isn't a bad credit score to me
that's perfect it's like it's like yeah
it's a no hitter in baseball and and so
the if you if you have bad a bad credit
score is an indication that you haven't
been keeping up on your debts that you
are in bad debt and you're not able to
pay off those debts and so I'm not
worried about the score there I'm
worried about the debts that you have
and so in summary know don't worry about
your credit score and credit cards if
you're in debt you shouldn't have any
credit cards at all and as Ryan said you
definitely need a safety net even if
you're in debt you need a five hundred
to a thousand dollar safety net I keep
mine in a separate account I use a
company called betterment to do that you
could put it in a separate checking
account you want to put it somewhere
where it is difficult for you to get to
that money you don't want to sitting in
your checking account
my safety net because then of course
you're gonna spend it oh I you know I
need a new pair of shoes or whatever all
different of my safety net safety net is
for true emergencies and emergencies
only once you're out of debt you
they want to have a much larger safety I
have a six month saved safety net and
that means you know if the internet
blows up or I stop making income for a
while or whatever it may be I have
enough money to live off of for for six
months I didn't always have that but
after I paid off my debt I built up a a
safety net so I would I would have more
security our next question is from
Jonathan in Maryland so I have credit
card debt obviously a higher interest
debt as well as student loan debt and
something that I find hard to do is
start to save or invest when I have this
other debt I feel like I should pay down
all that debt before I can start saving
any money for the future Jonathan first
off congratulations on making the steps
towards paying off all of your debt
right now you need to have what Josh
said in the previous question the five
hundred to a thousand dollar safety net
that should be goal number one before
you invest in anything that's for sure
and then yeah I would say right now pay
off all of that debt before you start to
invest massive amounts of money into
anything but the debt should definitely
get paid off first I agree with Ryan you
don't want to make any investments any
long-term investments in retirement
while you're still in debt your money
should be going toward paying off debt
however I could tell you what what I did
I also built a investment muscle over
the four years that I was paying off my
debt so I had about six figures worth of
debt and I really just laser-focused on
paying off that debt in fact if you want
to see the the exact plan that I use and
then Ryan later used to pay off his debt
as well we wrote about it on our website
it's at the minimalists comm slash
freedom we'll put that in in the show
notes there it's called financial
freedom five difficult steps to get out
of debt create a simple budget plan for
the future and regain control of your
finances and it's five difficult steps
for a reason it's it's definitely not it
is simple but it is not easy and so over
those four years
I made sure that I was putting all the
extra money I had toward paying off debt
I mean really when you think about it
Ryan that there are there are three ways
that we three things we can do with our
money we can either save it we can spend
it or we can give it we can contribute
beyond ourselves right and the only way
to get off des we're basically making up
for money we already spent that we
didn't have so in a way paying off debt
is spending money and so what what I had
to do was put all my extra dollars in
toward paying off my debt but at the
same time I would dedicate a dollar a
day just a dollar a day toward investing
in my future and I mean let's face it a
dollar a day isn't a big investment it's
not gonna make you rich in the long run
but what it did is it really developed
that investing muscle and I invest in
index funds if you want to see exactly
how I invest all of my retirement money
now and Ryan uses the same same formula
here you can go to the minimalists com
slash retirement I invested in several
different buckets but upfront I would
just put it into a wealth building
bucket I use a company like I said
before called betterment you can go to a
local broker as well or you can go
directly through Vanguard or or other
places III just invest in basic indexed
funds and and by putting just a dollar a
day in there it didn't make me rich but
it over time conditioned me to continue
to invest it's a great idea because
everyone can afford a dollar a day man I
mean if you're buying a cup of coffee or
if you're stopping at the store to buy a
pack of gum like everyone is spending a
dollar to even if you're going to a
coworker at the end of the day if you
don't have the dollar like hey can I
borrow a dollar
I mean dollar days is not it's not the
hardest thing in the world to save and
yeah that's that's the total totally
awesome exercise to get people in the
habit of saving money and investing for
sure and that's exactly what it was an
exercise so that after I paid off all my
debt after those four years and I became
debt-free and jumped up in the air and
all fat-free no code Dave Ramsey open
your like I'm free
not exactly but I felt that way and I
mean it just removed this huge anchor
and now I I dedicate 20 percent of my
income a minimum to to my investment but
that's because I already built that
muscle now every single month like
clockwork 20% of my income and at the
end at the end of the month after my
budgeted for everything I have
any money left over I put that into my
investments as well and you can see the
the four different buckets they're over
at the minimalists calm slash retirement
that article is a long article but it's
called a retirement planning how to plan
for a successful retirement and so yes
Jonathan you're not going to want to
invest big time right now you don't want
to contribute a bunch of money into a
401 K or a 403 B or a Roth IRA or
anything like that what you want to do
right now is pay off your debt and at
the same time if you can just build a
little bit of a muscle so that once
you're out of debt
then you're gonna you're gonna be good
to go you're gonna be saving for
retirement or for a house or for
whatever else you you plan on saving for
in the future but right now say laser
focused laser focused on paying off that
debt I think both of those those
articles long articles on our website
will help you will put both of those in
the show notes as well Kim in Boston has
a question for us a little background I
have $70,000 in federal loan debt and
for a master's degree which I use to get
a job in the nonprofit sector so working
for an international development
organization so really doing what I love
and feeling like I contribute to society
but for a low salary which makes it
really difficult to pay back that
federal loan so I wanted to know what
you guys think about federal income
based repayment plan programs and moon'
forgiveness programs I'm actually in one
of these the one I'm in calculates my
payments at fifteen percent of my income
and generally the forgiveness program
works in after you make twenty five
years worth of payments they don't have
to be consecutive the government will
for
of the rest of your loan now there's
also a piece if you work in the
nonprofit sector like I do or in some
sort of public service they will forgive
your loans after 10 years worth of pain
and so after 120 payments so this makes
my payments manageable the one little
bit of concern I have I'm locked into
7.25% interest rate so it's kind of
scary when I see my loan statements that
the principal is actually increasing
over time because my my income based
repayment rate is not even touching the
full interest so I know if I stay in the
nonprofit sector after ten years I'll
get that loan forgiveness but it's still
a little a little overwhelming so I'm
just kind of curious it seems to me that
this goes kind of counter to a lot of
advice you're giving around mortgages
and whatnot where you don't want to be
in locked into long term plans but if
you're working in the nonprofit sector
you know and this seems like a viable
option particularly a federal loan you
know kind of what do you think about
this and then my particular situation I
mean I can't take back the fact that I
went and got this master's degree but
this is how I'm dealing with it right
now you know if it is a loan that you
have signed on the dotted line and that
you've taken on you know I would say pay
back your loan at all cost I mean that
that goes for anyone out there I don't
think there is any you know any any uh
justified way for anyone to just like
stop making payments and to ignore alone
that there's no doubt about that however
there are some times when people get
themselves in a situation where she has
a seventy thousand dollar student debt
loan at a seven percent interest rate I
was like doing the math on this before
the podcast just on the seventy thousand
is five thousand dollars a year that
doesn't include compounded interest so
so if she was just paying on the
interest it's like four hundred bucks a
month so basically what I'm getting at
is this loan is upside down at this
point
so sometimes people get themselves in a
situation where they can't pay back the
loan they're doing everything they can
they are making the pain
but they are unable to pay it back and I
would say that yes there are there are
some government-funded subsidized
programs in place that will forgive
loans I know people do this with with
mortgages where they can short sell a
house to avoid bankruptcy I think those
those are in place for a reason and I'm
not saying that everyone should take
advantage of those like I said at the
beginning of this answer everyone should
pay back a loan that they have agreed to
take out on a certain interest rate now
maybe you can get that interest rate
lowered there are other ways to
potentially pay back that loan without
having a short sale there are other ways
but sometimes there are not and in those
cases I think that it's okay to take
advantage of those programs that that
help people to avoid bankruptcy seventy
thousand dollars in student loans it's a
ton the average american leaves college
with approaching forty thousand now Wow
and and in fact I've talked to a dentist
who had $400,000 in student loans and so
maybe maybe we'll talk about that at
some point but there's basically two two
ways for you to pay off this this debt
Kim one is to spend less money or two is
to make more money and and I'm gonna
give you some examples when I was
starting to pay off some of my debts
I delivered pizzas for Papa John's
several nights a week just to make some
additional tips and income to pay toward
my credit cards I wish you BIR would
have been available then because I
certainly would have just become an uber
driver that aligns more with my values
than delivering pizza but but but what
I'm saying is there are other ways for
you to make additional income and you're
going to have to scrimp and save because
I don't want you to be tied to this debt
if you imagine the two programs one was
25 years one was ten years I don't want
you to be tied to the $70,000 for the
next decade that sounds crazy to me I
don't want you to have to go through
that it's so stressful you don't want an
anchor hanging around your neck for a
quarter century or even for ten years
and so I want you to find ways to bring
more money in is there are there other
ways for you to use the degree that you
got to make more money
and at a different company if so that's
great if not what are you gonna do in
your free time whether it's opening your
own business or doing something on the
side like uber delivering pizza find a
way for you to earn more income so you
have the opportunity to to pay that off
and then of course if you have to
leverage certain programs I understand
that but but you don't necessarily need
to be tied to this debt in perpetuity
you're gonna want to get on a budget you
can use an app like every dollar which
is a great app I used to just do it on
on paper and mint.com is what I used
back in the day because every dollar
calm wasn't available yet but you want
to get a very tight budget and if you
get on that budget and you stay close to
it and you find some ways to make some
additional income you over I don't know
how much money you're you're making
right now but I think over the course of
a few years you'll be able to pay down a
significant amount of this debt not just
the interest but pay down a significant
amount on on the principle and that will
really free up Kim I'd love to send you
a copy of one of our books as well since
since you're in debt I definitely don't
want to charge you for a book we're
gonna we're gonna give you a copy of
essential it's a collection of 150
essays that Ryan and I have written over
the last five years about intentional
living there are our twelve separate
chapters in there about different areas
of life and one of those chapters is on
finances so I hope you find some value
in that book I hope you enjoy it
our next question is from a Maryland New
Mexico I lost my job a few months ago
and my husband and I decided that I
wouldn't work and be a stay-at-home mom
we are operating on my husband's income
now and I would like to implement the
needs once life strategies for budgeting
that you mentioned um I want to get out
of debt and stay there my husband and in
hand filled our debts of car payment
mortgage no credit card bill are minimal
compared to most people and didn't want
to change how could I introduce him to
your strategy and you have suggestions
on how we can work together to eliminate
our debt at a rate we'll both be happy
with
maril your husband is wrong but you
can't just go tell him that obviously
and and so the reason that you're having
trouble communicating here is you're
both talking about the what right now
you're talking about I want to get out
of debt or I want to stay at home after
I lost my job or or I want to have these
bills I want to have these expenses
these are the ones we need to talk about
the why why do you want to be debt-free
why what anchors are you removing what
will that free up will it give you more
time to to stay at home it sounds like
you want to be you want to stay at home
I don't know if you're a stay-at-home
mother but I'm gonna recommend that you
actually get a job until you pay off
your debts right now you're if you're in
debt you you want to be able to tackle
that as quickly as possible but you need
to show your husband why that is so
important financial freedom is going to
allow you to travel more what are your
goals how are you going to get on on the
same page now I know you said your
husband says that well our debt isn't
that bad compared to most people well
yeah if you could pay yourself to most
people you're never gonna be happy in
fact I think comparison just by itself
is is dangerous but compared to most
people most people aren't happy most
people are up to their eyeballs in debt
most people aren't living a meaningful
life and it's not because they don't
want to they certainly want to but they
feel trapped and quite often they're
trapped by this thing called debt and so
yes you definitely want to to get out of
debt and and you're gonna need to have a
discussion with with your husband you
need to get you're definitely gonna need
to get on a budget where you you find a
location for every single dollar that
you bring in and hopefully you'll both
be working to bring in more dollars so
that you can pay down that debt your
budget then becomes a contract with your
husband it's also a contract with
yourself but you really can't start
working on that contract until you get a
clear reason why you want to do this the
what is the intellectual side of things
in intellectual the intellectual side of
things does doesn't explain much
in terms of the why the why is the
emotion that visceral feeling behind why
you want to be deaf for you it's where
you're going as opposed to where you are
and just real quick you mentioned Meryl
our need want like list it's a budgeting
tool that Ryan and I have used to to be
more aware of the money that were that
we're spending and so for those people
who aren't aware of the needwant like
list you can just go to the minimalists
comm a slash want we break it down for
you there's three different categories
you put all your expenses in and I think
I think that'll help other people out as
well
yeah Meryl I'll talk about Mariah and I
am so Mariah's Ryan's partner by the way
yes
Mariah and I were talking about her
quitting her job this was about eight
months to a year ago and I was like you
know you can totally do this let's let's
talk about getting you debt-free let's
talk about you know getting a six month
salary safety net put together and and
maybe you could potentially quit your
job and that was a common goal that we
both kind of found that we could both
work towards because we we want to be
around each other more she wanted to do
more you know she like she looks at me
and she's like man I want to live that
blog life Ryan I want to like you know
be able to you know have freedom with my
schedule even though we work a ton you
know our schedule is pretty much ours to
manage so that's really you know what
she wants to work towards is having
having a schedule on her own terms and
she really really wants that so first I
would say Merrill is find something that
you and your husband both really really
want and and use that as leverage to to
pay off debt and to work towards and and
then you know got to a point where with
Mariah III just one day I was like oh
wow if she sells her car that would like
get rid of most of her debt already in
fact that was her biggest debt that
wasn't it was the only debt she had
yeah so I'm like man if she could sell
her car she would be debt-free oh by the
way she's been making double payments on
her car
so then she'd have a few thousand
dollars on top of a you know after
paying off the debt she'd have a few
thousand dollars to put away into
savings and long story short and once
we're and I'm like Mariah you could sell
your car we can go down to one car and
and you can even get there faster and
her initial reaction was no I don't want
to sell my car like car a car especially
in Montana it equals freedom in a lot of
cases you can get around Missoula really
really well without a car outside of
Missoula it's very very difficult to get
anywhere if you don't have a car so she
didn't want to like give up this
personal freedom but then as time went
on and wasn't that much time just a
couple weeks maybe a month where she
started to realize like oh yeah if I
sell my car I can quit my job a lot
sooner so she literally just sold her
car last week so the job was the pain
point there yeah it was more pain than
getting rid of the car it sounds like
exactly so so she she sold her car last
week and basically was able to put a
huge chunk of change into savings she
doesn't have that six months yet but she
will have that six months salary saved
up by the end of August and that is when
she will she will quit her job so her is
a plan yeah so she's got a plan so what
I'm getting at is is that you know more
I didn't want to give up her car and
then saw the benefits of giving up her
car so all the benefits of getting you
know of leaving that huge pain point of
her job and all of a sudden that moved
her - yes let's go down to one car now
the car that she had it was a like a
Chevy HHR like not a super you know nice
car but it was a nice right I mean much
nicer than my 2004 Toyota Corolla I
think it was like a 2010 or 2012
something like that but it had a you
know you know sunroof that didn't leak
it had um heated pleather see yes it did
have heated seats but it was awesome so
like there's all these like luxury
you know amenities amenities am I saying
that right yes I had all these amenities
that that she really enjoyed however
once we were able to find a goal that
that that equalled more pleasure than
the pleasure of her car she was able to
kind of turn that corner so find
something that you that you all have in
common if whether it's you know big time
vacation or whether it's you know
traveling the world for a year or
whatever it may be just find something
try to find something that you both can
work towards that that includes paying
off your debt I totally agree with that
we do things for two reasons either for
pain or pleasure so fine fine both in
the situation Meryl fine
the the pain points that are there pain
points for both of you and then find the
pleasure that you are both going to work
toward together and then if you want an
additional perspective Marilyn and maybe
your husband does too we'd love to give
you so our documentary is coming out on
August 2nd online and and so we let's
send you a copy of that when it does
come out online and there's six hours of
bonus content with with the Vimeo order
there so we're gonna give that to you
for free and maybe you two can sit down
together and watch that and find a bunch
of different perspectives there's a
bunch of different people in this
documentary who are living a meaningful
life with less we have minimalist
families minimalist entrepreneurs
minimalist architects and artists and
and writers and we also interviewed
neuroscientists and neuropsychologists
and journalists and even a former Wall
Street broker and a bunch of different
perspectives on how to live a meaningful
life with less so we'd we hope you enjoy
that film and maybe your you and your
husband could watch it together and get
some value out of it and find all of
these different perspectives and of
course we'd love to hear what you all
have to say about money if you have a
comment about money or or or debt or
budgeting or minimalism tips for how to
handle
debt and pay off debt and invest then
leave us a voicemail at four oh six two
one nine seven eight three nine we'll
air our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode alright let's move on to
our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we're on
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
and facebook.com slash the minimalists
alright our first question is from
Kenneth what advice would you offer a
grad student who is barely breaking even
and is trying to pay for a simple
wedding Kenneth I'm gonna be honest with
your brother if you guys can't afford
your wedding you might not be ready to
get married and I'm not saying that to
be mean I'm just I'm just being honest
man now let's say you're in a situation
where it's religious reasons so like
you're living in sin and you know you
feel like you got to get married to
avoid living in sin then go get a load
you don't have to have a wedding though
that the marriage is not about other
people the marriage is about you so so
again if you are if you're not religious
and there's no reason to get married
right now I would say hold off on the
wedding and that's the take take it or
leave it that's my that's my advice if
you are someone who is like I said
needing to get married for religious
reasons or some other you know major
reason that you have to get married you
got to get on somebody's insurance or
whatever it may be then go get a lope
and then have the party later but but I
always find it funny how people they get
in debt over weddings over one day a
year they will go into thousands and
thousands of dollars of debt so they can
impress their friends and family thirty
to fifty thousand dollars quite often
it's it's amazing and so I I completely
agree with what Ryan's saying here and
if you're going to have a wedding a
simple wedding remember who the weddings
for it's for you it's not to impress
your friends or family it should be what
you want and you also need to be ready
for it and that means you need to be
able to afford it when I bring a new
purchase into my life I asked two
questions can I afford it and
this add value to my life and I would
encourage you to ask those same
questions with with your wedding can I
afford it right now meaning am I gonna
go into debt if so then no you can't
afford it
and believe me III got married when I
was young and we had a fairly elaborate
wedding
Ryan remembers he was in the wedding
party and we had a stretch Hummer at one
point and it was good God we did have a
stretch hello so it was that good we
spent a ton of money and and my former
spouse she's a wonderful woman and and
she wanted this elaborate wedding her
dad actually helped pay for some of it
but her parents are both factory workers
they didn't have a lot of money and so
we ended up just taking on the debt we
put it on credit cards and a bunch of
other stuff that was part of our six
figures worth of debt was was building
up this elaborate wedding and so you're
I'm sorry you were married for how many
years I was with her for eight married
for six ok married for six years when
you were divorced we're still paying off
the wedding that is true Wow that is
absolutely true and and that's why that
is that that's insane lightning yeah
really is me when you think about about
the ceremony itself last something like
16 minutes and and so it's not a this
lot and then you have of course a
celebration or whatever afterwards
who's the celebration for though it's
for you dude I don't mean to be a jerk
right now but ice besides like taking
pictures outside the stretch Hummer
uh-huh like we would have to like have a
conversation for you to really jug my
memory of the wedding yeah like I really
don't remember the reception I barely
remember being in the church no I
I remember being beautiful I I remember
nothing that was a memorable position is
you man yeah like I remember showing up
and like having a tuxedo I barely
remember my own way to yeah well yeah so
yeah the wedding is for you if you're
going to have it and just keep that in
mind
we're not there to impress others all
right our next question is from Lee ho
I'm finally debt-free
gratulations woo please guide me on how
to go about investing in the stock
good please give me some beginners tips
well I say put all your money in Enron
Wow for those of you who haven't seen
the Big Short that didn't have to do
with with Enron necessarily but the
financial collapse of of 2008 that was a
great film
that's shows us what not to invest in so
let's talk about how to invest your
money so let's go back to the retirement
planning article which is the
minimalists com a slash retirement and
I'm gonna sort of guide you through some
retirement or some investing principles
really because that's what we're
investing in we're investing in the
future as I mentioned earlier there are
three things you can do with your money
you can spend your money you can save
your money you can contribute I'll tell
you the order that I do it in I save
first so if I if I make $100 I save at
least $20 and then I contribute if I
make $100 I give at least $10 it's
generally more than that and then I have
the other 70% to live off of and
generally I have plenty left over to
invest and to contribute beyond myself
but we're really talking about that
saving part we're saving for the future
whether that's to to buy a house one day
or for retirement etc I invest my money
in index funds and the reason that I
prefer index funds over mutual funds is
the stock market tends to outperform
about 90 plus percent of mutual funds so
an index fund like the S&P 500 is is a
really good place to start I use a
company called betterment and you can
see exactly how I invest my money in two
different different buckets but I want
to really go through right now there are
seven retirement myths that I wrote
about in that retirement article and
these are really seven in investment
myths as well so myth number one I'm too
old to save for retirement and so I
remember that back in the corporate
world I frequently hired employees who
were older than I was you know I was in
my 20s and Alford hired people in their
30s 40s 50s
sometimes and and a lot of these people
had no retirement savings plan and I
think fear had long ago set in in their
lives and they figured it was just too
late for me I am stuck I missed my
opportunity to invest in the stock
market and and nothing could be farther
from the truth
while it's true that you're better off
starting at age 25 then if you or aged
50 it's also true that you're better off
starting at 50 than age 70 and you're
better off starting at age 70 then at
age 90 the past is the past
and we must stop looking in that
rearview mirror and instead start
looking toward the horizon and that's
what investing is going to do for you so
as long as you're still breathing it's
it's never too late to start investing
and it's never too early either of
course so myth number two is I'm too
young to save for retirement for
retirement too young are you crazy
like if you're younger than 30 years old
which Ryan and I aren't then man you
have it made young people no matter your
tax bracket have a significant
opportunity to become truly wealthy
thanks to the power of compound interest
Ryan mentioned compound interest earlier
it was respect to the debt that this
woman had on her college loan that's the
wrong kind of compound interest but if
you're investing your money you get
compound interest on that that money
that you're investing so let me give you
an example here
someone who invests twenty five thousand
dollars by age 25 with a twelve percent
rate of return will have more than two
million dollars saved by age 65 that's
without adding another dollar after age
twenty-five Wow now if you do that at
age 50 you're not gonna have as much
money because compound interest real it
really is on your side in that the 12%
that is like the average rate of return
on the on the stock one yeah yeah so so
we'll go over some we can go over some
percentages here in a moment
twelve it is a little bit better than
the average but we can even adjust those
numbers and say okay what if you get
just the average which is 11% or just
over
11% I believe over a long period of time
now last year the stock market lost I
lost about 2% on my investments last
year but over the course the last eight
years I'm more than doubled my
investment and so it's important to
realize that yes the stock more is gonna
be volatile at times there'll be
downturns but we're talking over a long
period of time so that same person
conversely if you if if you instead of
wait till age 25 you wait til age just
age 30 he or she will have contributed
will have to contribute more than three
times that much so 25,000 or 75,000 at
age 30 will Ryan and I are both through
35 this year and so it's good would be
even harder for us at that point so know
you're never too young in fact when
you're young it's absolutely the the
best time to do that and I think the
lesson is that compound interest is the
best way to grow your money over the
long haul so start while you're young if
you can and myth number three we'll move
on to that I don't make enough money to
save for retirement and really were
saying there's I don't make enough money
to invest in my future self mmm Wow so
actually there's no reason you shouldn't
retire a millionaire what I was telling
back at this when we first met and she
actually got people get a visceral
reaction to so my partner backs it
because it sounds creative us aren't
millionaires I'm not a millionaire
Ryan's not a millionaire I don't know
about Shawn I don't know what he's doing
over there but I'm guessing he's not a
millionaire but there's no reason that
every single one of us shouldn't retire
as a millionaire and literally virtually
everyone in the Western world even
minimum wage earners everyone has the
opportunity to be a millionaire when
they retire and I know that sounds too
good to be true
but the math it proves otherwise and so
again a 25 year old who sets aside only
twenty three dollars per week 23 bucks a
week will retire with more than 1
million dollars if the money is is
invested appropriately so 12 percent
rate of return there and again so 25
year-old sorry
just explain to me a little bit so 25
let's say you're 25 years old and I
start putting $23 a week right now I'll
be a millionaire by the time I
by the time I'm 65 yes Wow that is
correct and so maybe you're not 25
anymore though
me either maybe you're 35 like josh is
gonna be later this month yeah actually
when this airs it'll be tomorrow Oh
we'll talk about that in a second
and I think that's okay I mean us older
folks we simply need to adjust
accordingly it's not gonna be $23 per
week but everyone at age 25 has the
opportunity to become millionaire and
even beyond that you just got to invest
more per week and if you don't have the
money like I said earlier you can find
other ways to get income whether it's
delivering pizza or it is driving for
uber or finding a higher paying job
learning a skill set starting your own
business and one of the best things Ryan
and I ever did was was leave the
corporate world because he gave us the
freedom to start our own business and
and yes we work a lot as Ryan mentioned
but we're in control of our own destiny
now you know before someone else was
writing our paycheck and we could be
fired in a day we could the company
could go under in fact we were talking
about this on on last week's podcast
Ryan we I said you know I'm about to
turn 35 and my plan was to be a senior
VP by age 35 right well think about that
if I would have stuck that plan out I
would that wouldn't have actually
happened cuz the division that we worked
for was acquired by a larger company and
everyone there was essentially right
sized yes I think I think that's the
appropriate HR term reappropriation oh I
had a boss once I one of my my favorite
mentors he when he would let go of
someone he said he promoted them to the
marketplace good good but you know it so
here's the thing you want some sort of I
don't know how old you are obviously but
you need a investment in retirement
calculator if you go to the minimalists
comm slash retirement there's a link to
one in there as well let's go through
these other myths really quickly myth
number four
inflation will hurt my investment nest
egg this is the only myth that that's
actually partially true however the
truth is irrelevant in this case well
it's true that a hundred dollars ten
years from now we'll probably possess
less buying power than $100 today the
flip side of that coin is also true and
considerably more important your $100
ten years from now will be worth
infinitely more than your friends zero
dollars that he invested amen in fact
solid investments are the only way to
outpace inflation some people are like
what does that buy gold right gold makes
about 2% a year on average and it's
really volatile it's it's not something
I would ever do I would never buy
commodities and in fact and so that is
any outpace inflation most years and so
it's better to invest your hundred
dollars now than it is to keep it in the
bank or under your mattress now you
might say I invested $100 and then the
stock market goes down 2% this year now
I have only 98 dollars that's true and
sometimes you you start investing at the
wrong time and that happened to me 2008
I lost half of my my net worth and my
401k basically and and I took me another
six six or so years to get that back and
then eventually start making more money
on top of that no it's funny like when
when the stock market goes down like
last year you know everyone lost 2% on
if they were invested in index funds
uh-huh I just look at it like oh wow I
should buy more index funds the stock
market is on sale right now yes that's
exactly what we should look at it but
our emotions don't let us do that oh no
there's a 10 percent dip in the stock
market great the stocks just went on
sale 10 percent and I think that's a way
to do it I don't invest in individual
stocks we could talk about that in a
moment
let's talk about myth number five first
though number five I'd rather spend my
money on something else instead of
investing well I get an intentions are
good and I think this excuse it
occasionally sounds like one of the most
compelling reasons to invoice saving for
for your future I think it's true that
sometimes we selfishly cling to money
we use our income to purchase like all
of these these trinkets and shiny
objects and the the trophies of
ostensible success basically new cars
and and new electronics and all the
accoutrements of consumerism but
frequently we want to use our money also
to contribute beyond ourselves to
charities and nonprofits and and of
course to loved ones in need and I think
contribution to others is certainly
admirably
and you know I believe ultimately it
what's the reason we live giving is is
living so of course I want you to
contribute generously but I've also
found that the best way to help others
is to help yourself first the best way
to give generously is to have more to
give right and so invest in yourself
first helps you flex your own giving
muscle there's a reason that airlines
tell you to secure your own oxygen mask
before helping others right if it's
easier for you to breathe it's easier
for you to help others in need
myth number six is the stock market
isn't safe oh no translation
you don't understand the stock market
and that's okay I don't completely
understand the stock market either not
intimately anyway I'm not a financial
advisor nor do I play one on the
internet or on a podcast the only people
who must have an advanced understanding
of the stock market and all of its
intricacies or stockbrokers and day
traders and and people like fund
managers and I think rather than
allocating several hours a day to learn
the nuances of mutual funds and index
funds and individual stocks I personally
I I choose to use an investment service
that basically takes the guesswork out
of it and I think it's true that any
investment is going to introduce risk to
the equation for you but in the long
term the stock market has proven to be
by far the best way to grow your
investment and retirement savings over
the last 25 years include
the the 2008 steep decline and the
subsequent Great Recession the market
has averaged a rate of return of nearly
11 percent even when you account for two
for 1929 s Great Depression so about a
hundred years ago now the market has
averaged greater than nine percent
growth over the over the past hundred
years and so even during the Great
Depression if you average that in it's
nine percent which is way better than
inflation way better than the the the
one percent you're gonna get in your
savings account or whatever it may be
way better than gold yes way better than
gold and we should probably chat at some
point so investing in the stock market
is actually the most stable good growth
investment one can make in the long term
especially when using online tools like
betterment or there are other ones out
there as well that they really help you
outperform the market in many ways and
do things like tax loss harvesting I
don't even really know how to do that
but a firm what like like betterment
does that for us so I don't even know
what it is really I just get an email
it's like hey you just made $200 on tax
harvest tax harvest harvest harvest yeah
yeah great basically they're there
they're constantly rebalancing your
portfolio so you're not spending hours a
week trying to do it yourself and again
this isn't just a plug for betterment
there are other ones out there as well
you can find a local broker as well and
the final myth that I have here myth
number seven I don't have enough time or
knowledge to manage my retirement
savings it's true that you and I will
will likely never have as much financial
wisdom as the experts the people you see
on the fortune magazine or whatever but
that's precisely why we must seek out
tools that help us invest our money
you know tools that are there developed
by trusted reputable experts and so
whether you're going with with better
men or your local broker find someone
who you can help leverage to help you
invest appropriately for sure I think
the reason I use online investing tools
is
they allow me to control my money
without being overtly controlling like I
I think it's a bad idea to log in every
day and see how the stock market still
doing I'll go on about twice a year
talk about a rollercoaster man yeah
you'll just get your emotions up in it
and an investment should never be a
emotional exercise there should be a
hundred percent intellectual exercise
this is the what side of things and
you'll understand the why that's the
emotion like I want to be able to have
security in retirement and so yes you
you want to invest your your money
wisely I recommend index funds and you
can find all the index funds and
everything that I and invest in and Ryan
uses the same formula as me over at the
minimalists comm slash retirement and
before we before we wrap up this
question I do want to talk about five
investments to to avoid real quick so
whether you use any of our tactics or
not I would definitely be remiss if I
didn't at least warn you about these
these investments to avoid number one
cash value life insurance cash value
plans such as whole life or universal
life or horrible horrible investments
life insurance should not be treated as
an investment it must be treated as what
it is it's insurance your car insurance
isn't isn't an investment right your
health insurance isn't an investment and
so if you have dependents then yes I
strongly recommend you do have life
insurance unless you are wealthy enough
to self-insure and even then is it often
makes sense because it's relatively
inexpensive to get a term life insurance
so you want to find good term life
insurance do not let anyone sell you any
life insurance that isn't term life
insurance and if your quote invested in
other types of life insurance I would
find a way to get out if if I were you
number two individual stocks unless you
are an expert day trader individual
stocks pose way too much risk to the
average investor you may want to do it
for fun sometimes or whatever if you're
completely out of debt and
and you want to give it a spin to you
know buy Google stock or something like
that but but the truth be told even if
your employer offers a quote special
rate for their stock I would not invest
any of my money into a single stock not
even reputable stop stocks like Apple or
Google with with good performance it's
simply too high-risk for my tastes and
so I want my money to grow over time and
I prefer to get rich slowly instead of
get rich quick because get-rich-quick is
a good way to go broke quick yeah and so
you know there's usually just a bad
outcome with trying to get rich quick
and so keep that in mind
I don't invest in individual stocks just
because I don't have the know-how number
three yeah I I have invested in some
like in Tesla and like SpaceX because I
do believe in those guys sure but I do
view it as entertainment
yeah it's also contribution right cuz
yeah how do I contribute to this cause
that I believe in right one way to do it
yes it to buy but I have lost my ass on
it over the last year it's even more of
a roller coaster than the index funds
there you go so number three is gold
silver and precious metals so we talked
about this a little bit but like
individual stocks these metals are
fraught which is way too much risk
especially when you compare them to
index funds and even worse gold and
silver just like oil are their
commodities and commodity prices are
manipulated by speculation and by some
but if you look at a chart let you look
at a commodities chart here's oil here's
here's gold it's all spikes all over the
place it's not like the stock market
where it's fairly steady there are
obvious spikes during you'll see some
stair steps or whatever right but if you
look at gold it's it looks like a heart
rate monitor right it's up and down and
up and down and it doesn't really tie
with actual supply and demand and I know
some people some conspiracy theorists
are really worried about well the US
dollars is is going to go to hell and
well if you look over the last 200 years
the the the best way to in
vest has been in the stock market and a
lot of that has to with u.s. dollar in
gold just like the the green paper that
we use is basically I mean there's no
intrinsic value in any of it it has
value because we give it value exactly
whether that's gold or silver or paper
money because we give it value for it
you you cannot go to the hole to Whole
Foods right now with your bar of gold no
they would let bottom food have no idea
what to do with your gold
exactly number four you do not want to
invest in annuities variable annuities
or really any annuity for that matter
they are are generally not a good
investment especially since there are so
many other great investment options out
there more often than not annuities are
rife with fees and penalties and
surrender periods not to mention pretty
crappy rates of return so I think those
are kind of yucky it's another reason
that I use an online firm like
betterment is the fees are pretty darn
close to zero your average broker local
broker is gonna charge you about 300
basis points which is 3% a lot of online
firms gonna charge you about 15 basis
points so 15 versus 300 basis points and
it's because they eliminate a lot of the
the middlemen so to speak and last the
other thing you shouldn't you should not
invest in or are just low interest
yielding investments if you're investing
for greater than five years then low
interest yielding investments such as
CDs saving accounts individual bonds and
things like that they're poor
investments because the interest earn
usually it doesn't outpace inflation but
yeah sometimes bonds or just a savings
account or whatever they can be great
options if you're going to to save for
fewer than five years if you want to
reduce your your overall risk looks like
Ryan I think we have one more question
here all right our last question is from
Reuben which debts do you view as
justified and which are not for example
mortgage student loans credit cards man
the word justified I like I love how
this question is worded yeah I usually
think that's a good question yeah
I think we used to say that to either be
patronizing or because we're trying to
buy more time but in this case though
the wording there yeah I think it's
great also though I think justify could
be a double-edged sword now yes because
here's the thing it's like let me talk
so let me just talk you through your
scenario I am a college graduate I have
no car I just got a new job and you know
wherever pura Peoria Illinois
III moving into a new apartment and I
gotta get a car so this is where like
you know people will justify getting
into debt to get a car now I think that
you know let's say that this person that
I'm talking about has zero savings and
there's no way that they can get you
know spend a thousand or two thousand
dollars on a of their own money or or
get money of their own to spend on some
kind of you know junker or something
like that to get them from point A to
point B yeah you know I think there is a
justification here to say okay I've got
to go get a car in order to get to my
job so I so I can you know start living
my life the problem is when people
justify well I got to get a car and they
don't go out and get a two thousand
dollar loan for a junker they go out and
they get a twenty five thousand dollar
loan because they're like oh well you
know my cards a minute two hours a day
and lions are gonna see my classroom is
saying I gotta have those heated seats
and I gotta have that CD player it's
gotta be a comfortable ride for my
commute and you know I would say yeah
you gotta have a car for if you got a
commute you gotta have a car um but no
you don't need the heated seats no you
don't need the CD player no you do not
need to get into $25,000 worth of debt
justifying it because this is what you
use the to get to from point A to point
B or to get to your job yes I do think
that you can justify getting into some
debt here but don't let the
justification let you go away above and
beyond your your means [ __ ] some of
this whole episode today sum it up with
eight words it would be there is no such
thing as a good debt right and and so
let's talk about this real quick there
for me there are two cases where I could
justify dead doesn't mean that's going
to be good because
was good I would just try to get more of
it write it but there are two cases
where I could justify it again if it was
a mortgage where I could pay put down at
least 20% for maybe 50% and have no
greater than a a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage for me I wouldn't do any any
greater than 7 years personally that or
a medical emergency if you have a
medical emergency and of course there's
gonna be some sort of debt tied to that
but ideally you have a safety net so
you're not going you see at least be
able to cover it if you have a safety
net once you've paid off your debt so
even then you're generally gonna have
some sort of health insurance and you're
gonna have enough money to cover that
medical emergency in your safety net
fund
otherwise no I can't justify any debt
even that $2,000 car I would bet you
there's a way that you you can find to
to get around this so there are very
rare cases where any debt is is
justified Ryan I'd like to try something
different right now since it's my
birthday tomorrow okay I'd like to do a
rapid-fire round of questions we had a
bunch of questions coming last night for
some reason about about debt so I
haven't read any of these questions you
haven't read any these questions and
then I'm just gonna give my birthday
rapid-fire response and if you have
anything to add to it okay if you're
good with that yeah go for it man
Colleen asks advice from merging
households getting married when one of
you has no debt me and the other has
$40,000 in debt well Colleen you are a
bit mistaken there's a crack in your
logic here his debt becomes our debt
when you get married so I need you to
treat it that way it once you're merging
your household you're gonna want to
merge your checking accounts you don't
want separate money and you're also
going to want to budget safely together
well I will say that maybe they do want
some like separate savings maybe but for
all intensive purposes agree for all to
talk about so you think Mariah should
put her 6-month safety net into my
betterment account if you decide to get
married absolutely not not do you think
I should have access to that six-month
safety net I think that if you're
married yeah absolutely you should if
joining your households together that
like is that like as a like a fail-safe
like if the other one dies like you have
access to and you don't have to go
through ya access to their account yeah
yeah I can see that you would want to
have access to it but but you also
assume it up Brian I are never gonna get
married though so there's no reason for
me to have access to her accounts yeah
exactly and go yeah but but is there
they're merging their households here
and and they're gonna want the same
checking account and basically you just
don't want to hide money from each other
of course no in that that's really where
I'm going here is you you do not want to
hide money your money becomes our money
when you're getting married so your
checking account should be combined
otherwise I mean the two things people
argue about or what sex and money and
money over sex usually so terrible it
really is and so the way to avoid that
have a budget every month realize this
is now our money it's not his debt
anymore it is also yours it's yours
together Emma asks about UK student debt
it's completely different from the US
and is the only logical way to go to
university for most people oh wow Emma
that's [ __ ] well it is with that
idea with that attitude
yeah I mean here's that here's the thing
you can go I mean there are there are
countries god I forget the name of the
frickin country but there are countries
where you can go to school for free like
you got to move there you got live there
yeah I mean even if you're an outsider
places like Denmark and yeah even if
you're a foreigner like you can go to
school for free Emma I think we both
realized that you're well you're not
lying to me necessarily you're you're
really lying to yourself at this point
the the student debt is debt it's not US
debt isn't different from UK debt okay
maybe it's in pounds versus dollars but
debt is debt and there are plenty of
people in the United States I mentioned
earlier I know so I know two dentists
this is this is a really interesting
dichotomy between these two dentists one
dentist who left school with $400,000
worth of debt one thousand I know
another dentist who also left once he
got out of university with
zero dollars in debt and so I talked to
him about how did he do that and he
saved up money working throughout out
the process they paid off some of it he
also worked for the the government for a
period of time mmm that helps so that
they paid a significant portion and then
to make up for the the money the gap
there instead of taking out loans he
worked for the University and they gave
him a stipend for four classes and and
my point is whatever you're trying to do
it looks like Emma wants to be a nurse
and in her previous tweet here you know
what there are no all you have to do is
find a nurse or two and see who got out
of school without debt no that's it
that's a goal of their template no
that's a good that's good advice man
because yeah I guarantee you there are
nurses in the UK who have went through
nursing school and left with zero debt
absolutely that's and that's all you
have to do otherwise you're not being
completely truthful with yourself you're
using words like it's completely
different it's the only logical way no
it's the only illogical way to get
through university because here's the
thing if you get out without any debt
you're gonna make a pretty darn good
income in the United States the average
the average nurse is gonna make upwards
of $90,000 that's pretty amazing but not
if you have a crippling amount of debt
so let that debt go and you're gonna
you're gonna be on the way to living a
amazing life where you can contribute to
others you can save for your retirement
and you can live within your means very
comfortably Maxine says what do you
think about borrowing for real estate
investment renting to someone that pays
the debt for you well I think real
estate can be an investment I don't
think your own house is an investment so
so let me let me delineate here your own
house unless you have a completely paid
off is an expense you're paying to live
there and there are other expenses
involved with any real estate broken
water heaters air conditioning units the
roof starts to leak they're all and so
it's not it's not good news when you
have these and so if you have debt
hanging over your head it's it's
certainly not an investment
and so having investment properties is
great if you can afford them you can
afford them if you can pay for them if
you have take out a mortgage it's not an
investment it's it's debt and so please
keep that in mind and your own property
it's it's your expense and I would treat
it as an expense and see you have a
completely paid off but I think real
estate for some people if you have a
knack for for real estate I certainly
want to want to be a landlord but one of
my best friend's is a landlord he has 20
properties right and he loves it yeah
there's a custom grass and everything
yeah like I know people who they've done
exactly what she's talking about like
they will finding you know a house with
foreclosures they get a really good deal
on it they take out a loan they don't
put you know hardly any down payment
down they take out a loan to pay for the
really good deal and then they will get
renters to go in there and rent the
property and they'll maybe charge them
you know 100 or 200 or is more than what
the mortgages so I do see that as an
investment but like I would never do
that personally because I know what it
is like to be a landlord and it is
stressful as hell yes so I will do it
for me right exactly but there are some
people out there like like Jamar anymore
yes loves it so could that be an
investment yes it would for me would be
a very stressful investment and for
anyone there is the potential of it
being a risky investment too right
because you know Omar's got 25
properties so if one tenant leaves and
he's got one place vacant that's not
that big of a deal but if you're someone
who buys one house right and you take
out a you know two hundred thousand
dollar loan and you're paying twelve or
thirteen hundred dollars a month on that
and you got a you know a tenant who
moves out you have a potential of having
you know a six month gap or before you
find another tenant so there's still a
level of risk there that you need to
need to be concerned with and the nice
thing about about Jamar in his case is
he
he owns about twenty properties now and
he never buys a new property that he
can't pay for in cash yeah and that's
the best way to do it he's in Cincinnati
and it's relatively inexpensive for him
to get properties where he gets it and
then he spends the sweat equity fixing
them up himself he'll take a $50,000
house and turn it into 120 hundred fifty
thousand dollar house when he's done
with it but he puts in the effort to do
that right and heap so he pays the money
upfront
and then he pays for the construction he
does it very slowly he's been doing this
for several decades now he gets a twenty
properties and then when he feels good
about it he'll add a 21st property and
that was twenty second property and
guess what he owns all these property
he's a teacher by the way so he teaches
during the day he's just a teacher
during the day I say earns his primary
income but then now his houses make way
more than he does at his teaching job
but he enjoys doing both you have to
enjoy doing it and I would say do not
get into debt to do it so he didn't just
go out and buy 20 houses and or pick up
20 balls and start to juggle them his
very first house was exactly he's
referenced in the last week's podcast so
yeah he went out bought his first house
and it was a foreclosure it was less
than ten thousand dollars and but it
looked like a ten thousand dollar house
and he put he put a year worth of work
into it and fix it up and finally
started renting it ringing it to someone
and and then you know eventually made
enough money to get his second property
and his third property and then you
bought an apartment building and and and
it just went from there so yes it can be
an investment if you can afford it you
wouldn't borrow money though to go put
it in the stock market either Natalie
says how do you feel about small
business loans borrowing money from
friends and family or raising investment
money it's all a form of debt I agree
although let me let me add something
here and this is I'm glad you asked this
because an important point to touch on I
would never ever ever borrow money from
friends or family and I also will not
loan money to friends or family now I
will give money to friends and family if
they need it if Ryan came to me and said
Josh man I'm really struggling right now
I really need a thousand dollars can I
borrow it from you I'd say no but you
can have a thousand dollars I love you I
care about you you can have this but it
changes the power dynamic in a
relationship when you do that you don't
want to be beholden sending your friends
and family and if for some reason you
default because you just can't afford it
it's gonna ruin that relationship
forever so be really careful from that I
wouldn't borrow money for the business
in general and I know startups or can
often be a bit different but personally
I don't want to get into more debt so I
would start your
business with what you can afford
there's a good book by Dave Ramsey we've
talked about him a couple times they
called entree leadership I would
encourage you to read that as well we'll
put that in the show notes yeah I would
say you know zero percent interest rate
from a family member is much better than
a you know five six seven percent
interest rate from a bank so monetarily
maybe it would be better to borrow from
a family member but there is so much
more risky than money if you're
borrowing large amounts of money from
friends and family okay real quick now
it's time for our our added value
portion of the show this is where we
each get to recommend something that has
added value to our lives and since we're
talking about debt today I'm gonna
recommend a few things Ryan and I a few
months ago recorded a money podcast and
you can find a lot of other thoughts
about money in there you can go back
into our archives over at the
minimalists comm slash podcast also a
chris hogan who wrote a book called
retire inspired has you could check out
that book or he also has a new podcast
that's coming out and i really saw it
was climbing climbing the charts so
chris hogan has that I mentioned earlier
but I'll mention it one other time if
you want to have a budget whichever one
should have a budget especially if you
are in debt
check out the every dollar app it's free
and it's over at every dollar calm yes
and if you are someone who wants to be
100 percent debt free and you have not
heard of Dave Ramsey check out his
podcast he's got a book called total
Total Money Makeover which is a
wonderful recipe to help people become
100 percent debt-free
check out Dave Ramsey and definitely if
you have time get his book and read it
Total Money Makeover let's move on the
right here right now this is where we
get to talk about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalists a few things
real quick our documentary at minimalism
a documentary about the important things
has hit Australia or it's coming to
Australia I should say in July you can
find that at minimalism film calm
there's also some additional dates in
Canada and we have about a hundred
screenings still going in the United
States before the online release the
online release happens
August 2nd if you want to preorder the
film and get six hours worth of bonus
con
you can do so over at the minimalists
comm a slash order also I'm teaching a
four week how to write better class let
me just warn you it's it takes a lot of
effort a lot of work so if you're
willing to put in a lot of effort to
improve your writing whether that's
business emails or writing a book or
improving your blogging skills I'm happy
to help you out but I put a lot of
effort into this class so I require my
students to do the same exact thing I
can't I can't just upload the knowledge
into your brain it's going to require a
lot of work on both of our parts if
you're interested in learning how to
improve your writing just visit how to
write better org and then also Ryan has
some mentoring that he does and he has a
whole team of mentors yeah if you are
someone who is stuck and you need some
guidance you need some help go to the
minimalists dot-com slash Mentors
and I have a whole mentoring team there
I've of course myself is on there a
gentleman named Cruz Spence who is who
is a wonderful relationship he's
wonderful with relationships just
hands-down anytime I need advice on
relationships that's who I go and talk
to there's a guy named Carl Widener on
there he he has operated multi a multi
billion with a be multi-billion dollar
business and he has agreed to to help
folks out with business plans and and
you know when their entrepreneurial
endeavors but he is a wonderful resource
that uh that yeah he's totally there to
uh for people to take advantage of and
he charges way way less on my mentoring
page than he does in real life um
there's Vick McGarry who is a great
health coach he helps Josh and I with
our diet and exercise especially when
we're on the road there's just a lot of
other people on there I want to sit here
and go through every single one but the
cool thing about it Ryan is that this
this the team when Ryan I first started
talking about this he did mentoring for
a long time yeah but the thing he told
me early on is I'm not a life coach
because life coaches don't have much
life experience which I thought was
interesting but he would often go to the
his mentors
to get advice for his mentoring clients
they said well wait a minute but I I'm
going to these people why can't I just
send people to my mentors directly so
this is a really a team of the people
who have mentored Ryan and yahweh's yeah
absolutely and and you know there is no
shame in having a mentor there is no way
in in the world I would feel as
confident as I do now and have the
knowledge that that I have now if it
wasn't for going to others for some
guidance so yeah check out the
minimalist comm slash mentors if you are
stuck I guarantee there's someone there
that can help you get unstuck finally
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi my name is
Claire I'm calling from Augusta Georgia
so I listen to episode 9 of podcast the
other day and it was the one on what NYX
and several people called in and you
responded to a couple questions when
people are asking about essentially how
to how to figure out what their passion
was and whether or not to pursue it or
invest in it and one recommendation I
wanted to give was taking the Clifton
strengths finder test I took it a couple
of months ago and found a lot of value
in it and helped to kind of articulate
for many things that were kind of hidden
passions of mine and things that were I
was kind of already doing maybe but
things that sort of um came naturally to
me and not only did I get back on hurt
my top five strengths were the reports
that the tests generate also gives you
some ideas on the types of jobs or the
types of activities that someone with
those strengths would joy hi Joshua
hi Ryan Jamie Britain's Lincoln
Indianapolis Indiana and I'm calling it
because somebody mentioned something
recently on the myth podcast about
wanting to simplify the social
engagement not feeling like they're
getting much out of it but not sure what
to do because they wanted to spend time
with friends and I had a suggestion
something I've been doing recently is
that I like to hike and I like to spend
time with friends so once a month I have
posted what day Park I'm going to be at
and recommending it basically invited
anyone in
take the contactless to join me there I
would think you've been carrying it that
over to just about any event so maybe
you could determine the things that are
most meaningful to you and then invite
your friends and family to participate
hi my name's just from Minneapolis I'm a
full time college student part-time
worker and my favorite way to unwind us
to go on rock climbing trips on my
travel tip for minimalizing travel
expenses is so simple that it feels kind
of silly to talk about but putting away
small amounts say 20 or 30 bucks a
paycheck allows me to take these trips
on a part-time budget without going into
any debt I use an awesome website called
smarty pig comm it's really effective
because then you don't see it and feel
tempted to spend it but really any type
of savings account or even just putting
cash aside some more space makes travel
totally affordable on almost any budget
all right Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine and
if you leave here with just one message
we hope you'll leave here with two
messages there's no such thing as good
debt but also love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
you